what keeps me up and is that we are
missing a lot of warning signs I was in
Italy recently and I went to Pompeii and
I was fascinating to to see a city that
was destroyed by by a volcanic eruption
and that had missed a lot of science I
mean there are a lot of signs that
something was wrong and there had been
an earlier earthquake and dogs were
running away birds were not singing what
it was not flowing and yet somehow
people went on about their business and
and I have that sense of foreboding and
I'm really buy by nature and optimist so
I don't like feeling that way there are
tremendous warning signs about what's
happened in this country to millions of
Americans I mean what's happened to the
middle class I mean it's not that we
have over 35 million people in poverty
just about 10 million people are going
to be added to the poverty runs from the
middle class now that's that's an
amazing amazing development and it means
that families whose children are going
to have to leave homes they are leaving
homes now moving into motels are moving
into homeless shelters and what are we
doing by not moving that to the
forefront of our agenda and our
preoccupations and of course health care
is a big part of it because half of the
bankruptcy in this country are because
of health care costs so not not looking
and not listening to warning signs that
are there is what keeps me up at night
and I don't want to sound like a Sandra
because it's not fun being Cassandra but
we all need to remember that Cassandra
was right and the cheerleading Trojans
were wrong and very dead at the end